what's up people this is Ruben report I
seriously hope you know my name at this
point I've got two great guests with me
a lesbian wearing flannel I can't
believe it I did it for you whitney
mixter and a man who wasn't happy with
his pants election when you realized
that one time you drew attention to them
a much more comfortable lewis Weitzman
from BuzzFeed two of my favorite people
and Ruben returning you guys have been
your veterans hey you're hardcore
veteran so I have a good feeling about
this show so here we go all right gotta
start with the most important story of
the week Vanity Fair released pictures
from the set of Star Wars Episode 7 the
force awakens so there's a there's a
bunch of pictures here Adam driver who
is in girls he's gonna play kylo Ren I
think he's gonna be the bad guy Lupita
Nyong'o is gonna play Maz Kanata there
is the name Toria here are a bunch of
galactic travelers and smugglers Oscar
Isaac is gonna play poker on Daisy
Ridley is gonna play great all right so
I've been saying how I don't like this
idea spoilers I think it kind of ruins
these things and yet I just did it here
so what does that say about me I'm not
so sure
so what I have to talk about Star Wars
that much but generally can we no can we
we can do what no I'm fine I'm good but
what do you guys think of like oh we
live in a time when everything sort of
gets spoiled like there's no surprises
anymore like I watched the trailer
I love seeing Harrison forward back and
Chewbacca but like everything kind of
gets pre spoiled these days doesn't it
this isn't really a spoiler because
we're getting them from Vanity Fair
they're from the studio they're not like
leaked right so I wouldn't call it a
spoiler but in terms of like surprises
it's true that we now get a lot more
information early on the thing that I
hate is that we get casting information
very very early so like for TV shows if
a character's leaving we find out like
six months in advance because we know
about the contract negotiations yeah
things that we used to not know about it
also really like takes away from
surprise of that yeah do you miss the
surprise we have no surprises anymore
because of social media and the stuff I
feel like people like need every piece
that they can possibly acquire to try to
piece the story together themselves so
it totally takes up you know the whole
reason that you're going to the movies
man I personally try to just never watch
anything whatever just oh my eyes
yeah so that nothing can nothin spoil
you yeah what captured your guy's
imagination the way Star Wars has
clearly captured mine is there anything
that did it for you that way as a kid as
a kid as an adult or I mean what are
Star Wars you know so Star Wars did it
for you yeah yeah I mean I watched the
original trilogy when I was young yeah
and and I think that I was young enough
that an episode one came out I wasn't
totally horrified by it like I was a
little bit like excited to see a Star
Wars movie in theatres how old were you
and the win won The Phantom Menace I was
13 so that's young enough that it's
still worth like on the cusp of being
like a little bit bratty about it but I
mean it was terrible but I like remember
like seeing at my parents and kind of
being excited and like jazzed about it
because you know waited in line for
three hours and it was like a Star Wars
experience then afterwards that kind of
like look on their faces when I realized
that like oh this was actually really
bad and I should be better right right
what would happen it for you you know I
was really into the Ghostbusters that
was really I really do have first and
second things are you excited for the
whole girl oh yes Kristen Wiig it
doesn't get better than that
that's amazing yeah I would construct
little cardboard boxes and throw them
into the middle of like my mom talking
with her friends in the living room as
the ghost catching bugs I'm creating my
own that's right mister suck it in the
evil in the room I guess you're so cost
effective I can't get over this did you
ever cross the streams oh yes all the
times I'm crossing the streams right now
yeah we've taken our relationship to the
next level yeah anyway clearly our most
groundbreaking story yeah what do you
what do you guys think there's all this
stuff does it ruin the surprise this
thing's not coming out till Christmas so
we still have like six months or are you
okay with getting it kind of leaked and
learning a little bit about the story
and the characters before head let us
know your thoughts in the comments right
down below local Republican actually
kind of cool Thomas Massie a libertarian
congressman from Kentucky is ready to
shake things up on the House floor
elected in 2012 Massie an MIT grad with
a successful tech company under his belt
is a character to say the least
not only does nastyona Tesla and live
off the grid on a self-sustained cattle
farm he stands for some pretty
progressive ideas the congressman is
against national surveillance
wants to repeal the Patriot Act it's for
industrial hemp and had voted against
John Boehner for Speaker of the House
not once but twice
Massie claims he's no superhero instead
he's just an ideologue saying if
something I care about lines up with
something a Democrat cares about there's
nothing that gets in the way of us
working together all right so the guy is
off the grid he's down with hemp he
doesn't like the NSA he's not a fan of
Boehner there was establishment
Republicans guy actually seems kind of
cool could either one of you guys ever
vote Republican I mean I could vote
Republican I agree with his ideal a
viewpoint of supporting the cause that
belief the law and not the not being
partisan but this guy just because he
owns a Tesla and like lives has solar
I'm just very impressed with the faces
like yeah I like Tesla's too but he also
supported the Defense of Marriage Act he
is pro-life he's for offshore drilling I
mean there's a lot of very Republican
things that are still going on that
Trump him being just like
environmentally sound yeah so you could
vote Republican just not this guy I mean
I could if his his or her viewpoints
lined up with mine but so far it hasn't
happened ya know what do you think about
this hemp off the great that's the
driver I think you're giving too much
credit to being off the grid there's a
lot of people who live off the grid who
are like not cool and I'm totally crazy
right like they're really stoned like
people who are like way off the grid who
are paranoid yeah and like like I don't
know if I mean he seems cool enough yeah
kind of not based on everything else he
believes in but like I don't know if
he's actually chill or just like really
scared of the government like no gonna
say I live on my own I'm like I'm like
really high all the time
yeah and now we don't know that he's
smoking he just wants him okay happy
could build a rope hurry those
my mind is long by this story because I
just don't get what makes that guy also
please reference back the photo of him
that guy looks awesome like I want to be
like him like no you know I'm not
judging a book by it's cover there but
even when I opened the book and read
some pages I wasn't super stoked I was
really into the Tesla I just really
liked the test line I like the idea of
off the grid but actually I'm gonna
backtrack a little bit cuz I think you
are right like when I think of someone
off the grid I think of like this sort
of grungy kind of dirty guy that has to
like do [ __ ] but that guy I think I
don't think I'm the gun stockpile like
waiting for the government to come to
his guns away and it's just like ready
right what does it say about somebody
that would want to be off the grid yet
also be a politician like you wanted
that a politician is the most invasive
thing it's like seeing right what that's
like ch wants be a pop star but like no
one know what she looks like
ah that's slightly going over my head
but I feel like it's a good rest she's a
pop star she's facing the other way when
she performs or she covers her face
entirely yeah yeah she wants that be a
pop star and perform but like not have
the celebrity aspect of it right said so
she goes out but she will cover her face
she can like not be recommended guys
yeah yeah but she's doing it like with a
deliberate message of like I don't want
to have to deal with celebrity culture
but I don't think he's doing it like I
don't want to deal with politics I think
he's like possibly like watching illegal
pornography I go ah so he's off
electricity and internet and said
wi-fi's I'm like you know I'm saying I
think he's on the dark dog he can just
get like a like from a satellite
I'm just saying something is fishy with
this because his actual politics are not
in any way liberal really they're not so
there's the whole two-party thing seem
completely crazy to you like when I saw
this story the thing that I actually saw
it on BuzzFeed and the thing that seemed
interesting to me was that it was a
Republican that was a little bit
different and that just seems so silly
like that anyone does anyone either one
of you do you identify as a Democrat
then or like doesn't the label stuff
just identify I'm a registered Democrat
because I want to be able
the primaries and that's pretty much it
but I mean other than that I I welcome
people to change my viewpoints on other
on other parties I really look forward
to it
but if owning a Tesla is gonna separate
me from the pack like what the hell this
just seems like a bit big yeah I don't
identify as anything based on um you
know for work reasons I'm very privately
slash you could read my tweets and
probably figure it out like I'll just
say for now you know it's I I do I do
think that the folks got ideas and not
the party is interesting like if you as
you said it'll be better than a Tesla
and like some weird paranoid
off-the-grid stuff
alright I'm you guys have brought me
back your people I'm coming back and you
know what if you want to vote for a pot
smoker who wants a Tesla you could vote
for my friend Roseanne Barr who did run
for president has a great documentary
that you should also check out anyway
what do you think on this story a
Republican off the grid does it make any
sense let us know in the comments right
down below
apparently America is now post
post-racial that was quick
a new poll reveals Americans are bracing
for our summer of racial disturbances
across the country according to NBC News
in The Wall Street Journal ninety-six
percent of adults surveyed believe this
year's racial unrest is symptomatic of
broader national problems but African
Americans and whites are deeply divided
about why the urban violence is
occurring 60 percent of blacks said the
violence was the result of long-standing
frustrations about police mistreatment
of African Americans while 27 percent of
blacks claimed the disturbances were an
excuse to engage in looting and violence
white respondents had an almost polar
opposite response 58% said the violence
was an excuse to loot while only 32
percent claimed the events were because
of long-standing frustrations with the
police all right so clearly the most
interesting part of that is the end that
basically white and black people are
reviewing what's going on in the country
are now completely in Reverse now you
too are white am I correct which is
pretty much the worst thing there is two
this is three white people there is
nothing worse than it so let's three
white people talk about at least four
gay right at least three gay right
about race only that's the only saving
grace we have a little minority I'm
still taking my privilege like all the
time but like I at least have that going
so that will put you in the most special
yes here so as three white gay people
with a little bit of privilege and some
of its check there's something like that
did you think that after six years of
Obama being president that race
relations would seemingly be worse than
they were six years ago or are they not
worse and it's just some kind of media
construct or something like that I mean
I mean I think that what would happen
was is that it would be talked about
more like the concept of race and racial
improvement because I think a lot of
people put high hopes in Obama changing
the perspective of how people were
perceived racially and I don't know if
that happened I think that now more
discussion is being had and people are
kind of enraged and coming out in the in
the public and it's being heightened now
but I don't know this whole this whole
thing first of all the fact that 60% of
black people are saying that this is why
we're pissed off and white people are
saying this isn't why you're mad you
know it's like wait a minute no they
just said that's why they're mad right
like white people don't get to tell
black man what they can be mad actually
that's although they that way for the
entire history yeah you know not that I
defend Fox News often but you know every
now and again there'll be a black person
on Fox News and people will be like oh
that's just a token black person but you
know defending whatever but Who am I to
tell any black person what right they
think whether I agree with them or not
sure I'm no I'm just not shocked that
white people miss the point there Joe do
you think race relations are actually
worse they're like it seems I don't know
there's no worse but I think that people
were like are emboldened in a way to
kind of like speak out about the
injustice as they see in a way they were
before which is a great thing and
because of that they're a lot of scared
racist people who like are kind of
nervous and sort of saying the optical
in the opposite direction so they become
more not actively racist but like more
outspoken
there you know antic wouldn't believe it
kind of serves it serves the other thing
you know yeah it seems to me that just
there are always going to be a certain
amount of racist people but as long as
they keep that stuff private and aren't
trying to legislate on it or whatever
make it public then I guess it's okay
like you're allowed to wouldn't that be
an even if you know part of the system
yeah but they are you right yeah what do
we do to make some of this stuff better
I mean you're talking about it's good
right it's in the news now so that's
good and it's good to see that
minorities are feeling empowered that
they can do it but like what do we
actually I mean the root of the issue
has to be addressed here and and I don't
even know if we know what that is
people need to be hurt like actually sit
down and listen to why these people are
feeling so frustrated I mean the fact
that and also I feel like the media is
taking a huge card in this because you
know you're seeing the riots you're
seeing the looting and that's kind of
all you're seeing you're not hearing the
reasons behind you're not into not a lot
of people that are looting or being
interviewed right and and you're just
seeing this rage and being removed from
it even maybe in California which is a
liberal state you're still seeing this
you know really fueled emotionally
fueled response and you're not really
knowing what's behind it or what's
really going on and I on the same token
if you were to watch you know I'm sorry
but I've been living in San Francisco
now I was walking around after the
Giants won and similar situations were
happening and that was over them winning
the World Series right and white people
were burning cars but it was it for some
reason it wasn't viewed with the same
type of you know shock and dismay yeah
how much I saw as a guy in the media how
much this is actually cuz people say
this all the time like if the media is
only showing the writing but I don't
necessarily think that the media has a
narrative as much as the media shows
what will be clicked on right if someone
that burning a car or has a bat and
they're bashing a police car yeah the
media is going to show that like I don't
think the media people like to think
it's like a conspiracy like the media
sits down I'm like well gonna target but
I think it's just they will go to where
flicks well you can you can look to
BuzzFeed calm for more well-rounded but
I think that there are there is a sense
like people cover the
riots on the protesting that happens
before the riots they wait for something
dramatic to happen it doesn't look as
good for the protesters because you're
not you're right you're not hearing
their side of it you're not of seeing
the peaceful protests that that
sometimes erupt in violence but you're
focusing only on like the the burning of
cars right but isn't that just the
nature of what people watch like I don't
think we're doing this on YouTube I know
what people click on if we talk about
sex or beheadings they literally get
millions of views and if we talk about
political stuff again I like my mug on
fire if you guys smash her with them
that would not be posted on YouTube like
yes people will click on that now and
people are interested in seeing that but
is that because we don't have a strong
voice that is speaking out and really
pulling us in like I'm sorry but like
Martin Luther King we were all you know
and I mean not me personally because I
wasn't alive but you know everybody's
really just wanted to watch wanted to be
part and and it was not action so much
as words they were pulling people in and
I think we have a really strong lack and
that right now yeah do we just need
better leaders in general because I
would go on that like me not better I
think yeah why not Satur leaders leaders
where are you we need better leaders all
around anyway what do you guys think our
race relations worse are they better is
the media to blame is the media getting
together and secretly talking about you
and plotting how do you live your life
let us know in the comments right down
below as the Bible says thou shalt not
discriminate against atheists Madison
Wisconsin City Council has made a
decision to protect the non-religious
from discrimination but leave to be the
first statute of its kind in the United
States the law protects atheists and
other non religious persons from
discrimination in areas of employment
housing and public accommodations the
author of the ordinance Anita wire said
it just seems to me that religion has
spread into government more than I feel
comfortable with it occurred to me that
religion was protected through non
religion should be too so I do a whole
bunch of stories about atheism because I
really think there's one of the most
underreported things we see stories all
the time and polls that atheists are
actually the most hated group in America
I see on the left constantly people
turning against atheists which I cannot
believe there is no group of atheists
that I know of that is promoting hate
against people you don't see a lot of
these rallies where they want to kill
people and stop free speech and
bah-bah-bah why do people have a problem
with atheists I mean I I won't why do
you have a problem broadly I would say
it's because they're you know they're
religious folks we don't like people who
are not religious who are evens
but I thought religion preaches
tolerance that's a whole yeah but I
think the reason why a lot of liberals
don't like atheists because atheists
tend to be very loud and adamant about
something that no one's bothering them
about I mean I'm sorry I don't know what
happened to make her do this ordinance
but I don't know that she was actually
being affected in her daily life in any
way by not being religious or not
believing in God like I think she was
probably doing just fine right and I
don't wanna make assumptions but a lot
of times there are things that are done
that are more for the symbolic reasons
like you know I don't wanna be
discriminated against I don't think the
atheists by and large are being
discriminated against if you wanted run
for president run for office and in it
you have to probably if you were a
theist lie about that for example you
have to you have to be able like
religious in some way well that's
actually a great point because I'm
pretty sure that Bernie Sanders is an
atheist and he's running for president
but I would imagine that if it gets any
if he has any chance it's actually gonna
hurt him right right I mean that taste
sure that's a--that's a problem but I
feel like in most people's lives like
not believing in God does not have any
effect here's the thing i I think I
slightly disagree with why you think
that that people get so angry about I
think it's because you know it removes
that sense of hope like regardless of if
you consider yourself Jewish Muslim
Catholic whatever or agnostic it's like
you still have that sense of
spirituality which is like a sense of
hope in the world that there is more
right there and atheists kind of
challenge that concept and remove that
like they're like Matt this is it this
is the best or getting it right [ __ ] you
like no you're not gonna take this away
from me right and I think that's what
really what fuels that anger in that
discrimination and you know that kind of
makes them the ultimate other because at
least all religions they're all saying
there is something else there's hope for
more I'm
faith in something an atheist is just
saying no you can pretty much shoot that
right so I think a lot of people do I
think what I'm gonna talk about people
like I mean like I don't particularly
believe in a higher power
but I would but I don't identify as an
atheist because there's a connotation
that like people who are loudly saying
I'm an atheist but some people were
saying like I'm straight edge which like
if you're sober great and if you're like
okay I'm great cause if you're like
straight edge like I'm like why are you
like what are you talking with I don't
even know what straight it is that's the
one super so it's like it's it's a whole
thing but it's like you know saving from
from drugs and and like casual sex I
think it's part of but I I had a friend
who was like I'm really a strange no
like you can do all that and that's
totally fine and I respect your choices
yeah are you acting like you have to
proclaim that loudly right so it seems
to me that the reason that the atheist
have to do it is because I do feel like
they think they're under attack a little
bit in general because when they see
polls that say that they're more hated
than pretty much every other group I
think they feel that and then they are
loud about it so someone like Bill Maher
he's loudly an atheist because he loud
yeah and he has a show and he's loud and
outspoken that the reason he does it is
because someone has to I think in their
eyes
someone has to champion rationality
instead of I guess all that Hope stuff
that often isn't true their perspective
of rationality and like you're saying
that people that they're they're putting
clumping everyone else into the fact of
being irrational and you know but
they're just trying to put facts behind
things and break it down to simplicity
and and the fact of the matter is
there's no proof of any of this yeah
it's it's it's total hearsay whether
you're an atheist
you never had a spiritual God never came
to you in the shower or why do you
always come in the shower I mean I don't
know I was bar Mitzvahed but I'll just
I'll just say I guess so my wedding
gifts from strangers does not mean
there's a it does kind of well I don't
know it might no I think I might to my
point earlier like I think I would feel
the same way
about someone like in the first
conversation I have with someone if they
say I'm an atheist I'd feel the same
ways if they said like I'm a Christian
like I don't you know that it's not it's
our conversation it's not something like
I feel like should be the focal point in
your life yeah so that's kind of what I
mean by like you know starting off that
way I'm making it like a part of your
identity it's such a strong way the only
time truly that I ever thought I had
like some sort of experience with God or
a higher power saying I was in Amsterdam
for seven days I had smoked so much weed
I had trimmed a couple times and it was
like day six and I was in a hostel and I
didn't know what was going on and I
remember laying in bed and like I had
this feeling that like something was
there and I was like connected to saying
and I remember like two weeks later I
was just like I was just [ __ ] stoned
like I was jaw or does God just to come
to you when you're stoned how about that
but or you're tapping into that other
zoning your ring that allows you to
connect you know that's why I I don't
think that I'm gonna say this and I
think it's fact that we can look into
this no way you can say it either yeah
yeah it's fact this is factual that if
you get caught with over three more than
three sheets of acid you can get charged
with conspiracy to overthrow the
government because if you get that many
people together collectively out of
their mind what people say yeah it could
just open their brain into like a whole
new like you know expansive world where
you're thinking differently and flying
and you know taking it to the next level
does acid lead to God let us know in the
comments right now air is the new black
oil a Vermont man alongside singer Pat
Boone has created an eco-friendly car
that runs on compressed air I've seen on
ABC shark tank the duo pitch their car
to a panel of potential investors in
hopes of opening an Operations plant in
America to make their dreams a reality
based on the current prototypes the
vehicle operates on a propulsion system
not a combustion system and can reach
speeds up to 50 miles an hour the car
plans to retail for an astonishingly low
price of $10,000 all right this is
exactly what we've all been waiting for
right we were talking about the Tesla
earlier I love the test looks like you
would love you
I've been in it by having driven it's
like being an iPad it's really really
great anyway but this is even cooler
that forget electricity air a lot of air
we're surrounded by hair right now did
you know that it this seems great to me
it's cheap it's adorable it's adorable
it looks like the car in that the Larry
David HBO movie though yeah looks like a
lady but the red one car powered by air
pretty good right we have to get my
eyelids do do we yeah I don't know what
I think actually literally need to get
behind it actually push it after the 80
miles that it lasts for what that's like
at in best-case scenario a glass for 80
miles but isn't that just the beginning
of anything like that's is that you
should say about electric cars all the
time oh they're only going to go 10
miles an hour no we're never now we're
all driving electric cars well we're
getting there because of sending a Tesla
at least yeah exactly that's up there
are you people
let's go send my dress okay I just use
this I am concerned about putting that
much compressed air in a small space and
then sending it quickly down the street
where other cars could potentially
t-bone it and create a little come it
mean luckily it's like a little balloon
of explosion but still nonetheless I
don't think you're gonna make it out of
that one alive does this not seem crazy
that's like a science reason I talk
about not be able to drive the science
people are gonna be all over you i well
but air wouldn't explode or no I
researched this a little bit and some
people are saying 100% it would explode
you have compressed air in a small space
you combine that with heat from an
explosion I mean from a from a crash and
it's an explosion right there Wow
I put the kibosh I know I'm just like
it's too far but it'll get there that's
the point there's no but like in it you
know what I'm waiting for is the car
that can drive itself that's that's also
gonna be there in 10 years yeah I was
gonna know well we've done stories on
that don't you fear though that the car
better turn on you and kill you no I
want a car that will park for me yeah
all right so it's gonna parallel park
but then ultimately it will kill you yes
okay every week I do the Roger come we
have we have we're either gonna die from
cancer or we're gonna die from a robot
like you know what revolution yeah
they're gonna overthrow all of us so
either way we're kind of screwed so I
I'd rather honestly have the robots okay
would you guys at least accept why don't
we apply in car forget the I'll go with
you all right forget the aircar you
don't want the aircar no haircut what
about a fine I mean I think there's a
whole that whole like stop like traffic
signal thing like it would just be
free-for-all in the sky means traffic
sings so it's really about
infrastructure your training - all right
that's a very fact I thought it's - like
we get the signal up if you really like
take your car to like lovely but um no
also I just feel like why do we need
flying cars they're really cool to look
at but like practically like what would
that actually do you guys are the two
most literal guess I know well he's a
nature guy right so like he likes air I
suppose so I mean it's like being like
Neil Diamond is supporting you know I
don't even know so you got to finish
that I don't know now I just ruined her
pressure quick go I'm turning it on you
you're the host go Neil Diamond loves
solar power what do you think of this
story let us know in the comments right
down below you won't like me when I'm
angry
due to excessive steroids a Brazilian
bodybuilder has been hailed as the
real-life Hulk boasting incredible 63
centimeter biceps
unfortunately for Mario Alves is strikey
muscles weren't just the product of
bench pressing instead the man turned to
a lethal cocktail of oil and alcohol
injections called synthol to enhance his
arms after three years of habitual use
romário the diction turned deadly the
injections caused a buildup of rocks
yes rocks inside his arms while toxins
in the oil began to trigger kidney
failure doctors originally threatened to
amputate both arms but they were able to
remove this since all rocks and he made
a full recovery
Romario hopes his story brings awareness
to other athletes who are curious about
performance-enhancing
all right so we're gonna link to more
about the story right down below and in
it it's actually pretty depressing like
he ended up trying to commit suicide he
was in depression for a long time
clearly like some sort of body
dysmorphia yeah and all that stuff look
up my face and it's like I can't yeah go
go take it away now I just I don't like
muscles anyway
so that was a lot for me like a little
bit's okay look enough like you know
lift a bag but like past that no gross
what kind of gay are you gays are
obsessed with what is not true and you
know that's not true I live in West
Hollywood these people I live in those
feelings I'm fine yo see that's that's
what I should probably move to Los Feliz
yeah I mean this is actually kind of a
sad state it's raised I mean he was his
wife was pregnant you tried to commit
suicide during that time I mean he was
about to have the thing he worked so
hard for maybe didn't work hard for it
all but we're about to be amputated I'm
like is he was he did he have strength
with this product or is it just
producing like that's also working out
though so I think he probably had
muscles that were just kind of bigger
looking here's the thing that I'm
wondering about and I know that with
your extensive medical background yes
when these when these rocks are forming
doesn't it in turn kind of constrict his
actual muscle mass of like the ability
to grow yes well as a doctor I can
confirm that it right yes obviously when
you have giant arms like this like you
wouldn't be able to do certain things
but I always think this when I see these
guys with huge muscles in West Hollywood
I'm like you guys don't look like you
can move really so like could you even
throw a ball like yeah like practical
uses aside from second can you imagine
having sex with them no I'm saying like
like what do you hold on to you well you
can hold on to those two nodules
there's not even a muscle there that's
not like I don't know I don't know yeah
but they are like little handles no
suppressing other stories that they call
him the real-life Hulk he's not even
green so what's the goddamn point if
you're gonna tell yourself with
something at least include some food
dyes okay I'm like a full experience
well how much is do you think has to do
with just like the state of Technology
we live in where
everything looks better on everyone
wants to show off constantly on
Instagram and Twitter and Facebook and
like you filter things and you
manipulate things and you take 18
selfies so you always look great so
everyone always looking at things that
look better than actually I think you
could totally talk about like how that
affects body dysmorphia and like
anorexia and bulimia and all of its
weakness orders but this guy in
particular I feel like there's not so
much about Instagram and more about like
that particular lifestyle well yeah I
don't know maybe I don't fall enough
muscle people on Instagram but I feel
like that's kind of its own thing yeah I
think there's there is like I think
within that community like I just had to
get bigger and and just bigger yeah how
much for you like that that social media
party but you're a public person like
people are coming to yourself to see you
like that every you can manipulate every
image about you like it definitely
affects how we all act right I'm
horrible with posting pictures of myself
because I actually I have no shame or
filter like I'm not one for filtering
out or smoothing things I should the
other day I posted a video of myself
literally looking like a potato like my
Facebook like a potato and I didn't care
about me because you know what screw it
I just woken up I think and you know it
feels good cuz it's like I feel like
people can maybe relate to me more
that's what I'm telling myself to feel
better about the situation are you okay
looking like a potato let us know in the
comments right down below amazingly this
story has nothing to do with porn a 21
year old Chinese man collapsed outside
of an internet cafe after a 14 day
internet gaming spree after the
paramedics rushed the man to the
hospital to treat his injuries the man
baked the doctors to quote leave him
alone and turn on the computer because
he wanted to surf the internet a
spectator at the cafe claims she saw the
young man often during his two-week
bench during which he chain-smoked
hardly showered and ate almost nothing
the man known as mr. Shia claimed that
he had run away from home after becoming
hooked on online role-playing games such
as World of Warcraft and he had found
confidence in this virtual world
according to government figures out of
China's 649 million Internet users there
are an estimated 24 million internet
addicts many of them teenagers all right
so this is one of my high horse things
that we're all addicted to this thing I
don't know if you guys watched black
mirror but it's a great show on Netflix
all about sort of the future and how
this thing is connecting us
changing us they've done stories about
how the Internet is rewiring our brains
and our need for constant approval and
an immediate gratification and all that
is this like the next addiction thing
like I feel like in the 70s it was pills
in the 80s it was coke in the 90s maybe
it was every done with housing code I
feel like it's like slowly old school
you're all right that's all right yeah
then it was maybe coke or something and
then it was meth and like is Internet
addiction like the next that's not a new
thing though it's been going on for you
know since they didn't it became a thing
I feel like an addiction is not anything
anything new yeah but you don't think
these games are adding to it like I feel
like I totally agree with you I just
feel like it's not like a new thing
about this is this is ongoing I thought
there are stories like this all the time
yeah what do you think is this like
coming is this type of thing coming out
more that people are just literally
living in these words I mean that's what
he was doing he was living in a virtual
world
his body was just some vessel that was
to allow him to be in this other unit
it's becoming it's because we're
becoming reliant on technology in every
sense so we never get a break from it
with every new technological advance it
just removes one more thing that we can
do independently without technology so
it's you can't it's not like with coke
and with heroin like you nobody else not
not a lot of people around you are doing
it you know you're kind of in this
little bubble
unless you have a really good time but
here it's like everyone is doing it it's
around you all the time and you need it
to like get you from point A to B make
phone calls to feet find out information
and so it's like dangling the drug in
front of you all the time so you can't
escape it I think it's yeah it's just
gonna keep spiraling out of control
early do you feel like we're trapped by
it I totally I mean I I'd not be
something you do because I am obviously
there in an attic so I have to kind of
downplay it yeah I will say that I you
know my ex like many years ago was a
World of Warcraft addict and I there
were times that I was like I want you to
choose between I wanted to say I want
you to choose between World of Warcraft
and me yeah but I couldn't because I
knew what he would choose so um it was
it wasn't me yeah so I mean yeah I don't
know what the solution is I feel like
we're we're too far down the rabbit hole
yeah somebody for me the best of it yeah
so whatever we do these stories I always
ask everybody do you try anything to get
off the grid a little bit to do that
shut down cuz I'll like sometimes we'll
have a couple people over for dinner and
I'll tell everybody and just let's all
like put the phones away not look at but
then I noticed like we could go two
hours without the phones and everyone's
present and actually looking at each
other and like having real meaningful
conversation but the second one person
does it everyone gets like the clearance
and then everyone's like like do you do
anything to do the shutdown Oh 100% I
mean we'll have my wife and I do
no phone dinners all the time you know
it's like a rule
I've left the country before and walked
across and in the entire country of
Spain without my phone just to get away
just to disconnect you know it's nice to
do that you realize like after you go
through that detox period of feeling
like you know you are missing something
or need it you realize you're so much
more self-aware I mean you're enjoying
your surroundings more you're open to
experiences and new relationships and
ideas it's it's crazy how much this
actually even though we think it expands
our oh that really stifles our minds
yeah all right so how's it confess I'm
doing right you first thing in the
morning you wake up do you immediately
go to your phone before you brush it
mom's mad as I used to be honestly III
I mean this isn't some sounds
still bad ball I'll get into work first
I'll like drive to work and then check
my phone which is actually you know but
I mean do I go a whole day without it no
I couldn't do that but one day at a time
one day at a time all right there you go
one day at a time
anyway how addicted to this stuff are
you you guys know I talk about this all
the time I think and I suffer from it
too so I'm not being holier-than-thou
but I do try to shut down every now and
again let us know your thoughts in the
comments right down below this story
gives a whole new definition to the term
puppy love
it's final exam speak closer a college
in the UK has found the key to
distressing their overly caffeinated
students a puppy playroom organised by
the school Student Union in coordination
with the Guide Dogs charity attendees
are asked to make a small donation to
the charity in order to play with the
puppies which are all Guide Dogs in
training unsurprisingly the puppy room
is already fully booked with the
reservation list
some capacity so I want to do this story
because I actually have a friend that
when they're doing this in LA now to
parties you can rent puppies and then
you just get into a room full of puppies
and my friend did this and she just had
puppies jumping all over her she said it
was the most wonderful thing ever she
felt like some nothing better than
puppies yeah all over you is this just
the greatest thing ever puppies all over
there's a place called cat town and it
is a cat cafe and you can go in and I've
been there yes you can reserve a time
and you all go into this room and just
sit and hang out and drink coffee with
cats and pet them but you have to like
let them do their own thing well now I
know what we're making are different
yeah yeah puppies yeah I'm all about it
we had puppies in the office look at one
of those they like kind of corralled
them and we just like sat down and so
you did this no it wasn't yeah I mean
yeah it wasn't a therapy thing but it
was amazing it was therapeutic yeah sure
I mean this is the first time I've
wanted to go back to college like ever
yeah and it's because I want an excuse
to send the room with puppies yeah now
I'm a big dog I love dogs
I do not like cats I'm allergic to cats
which half my family's allergic to cats
and the other half has cats which I
always thought was there's some therapy
in there but you you like them equally
don't you because I see what you're
doing on Instagram you animals and you
know I think maybe they should do like a
new study where they just put like
really stressed out dogs in a room full
of babies and see what happens
they're like flip it around let's make
this interesting yeah babies yeah I
would not go well but no animals I love
them all I think that it's great that
they're using this therapy I wish they
would use rescue dogs to do this rescue
puppies maybe and that those awesome
like purebred so those guys in training
so they're at least like right so these
are these are guide dogs and training
and at the
that my friend did all the puppies were
up for adoption after so if you want but
yes they shouldn't be doing these out of
mills and are you equal are you equal
I'm allergic to cats
awesome alright and dog this is like how
does everything I think it's a gay guy
you think but I know I think that like
for me it's like I love them all and I
will totally deal with like three hours
of sneezing for the right animal yeah
they're just so cute
alright well I think we're all agreed
that this is all good so why don't you
you got a favorite animal rescue place
well no kill LA I'm a big fan of that
obviously because there no kill shelter
animal acres I'm a big supporter of them
they're a farm animal sanctuary located
in Southern California so yeah I just I
mean any place that's doing good for
animals I'm all about them yeah i-i'll
pimp those two out right now alright not
much debate here we all love animals
right you love animals don't you are you
a cat person or a dog person do you like
ferrets they like hamsters do you like
lizards what do you like let us know in
the comments right down below alright
that's the big show for you guys hope
you enjoyed it I'm gonna let you guys
pimp yourselves out do some branded
pimping right very fantastic you can
follow me on instagram and twitter at
whitney mixter la you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at louis pikemen
which Dave will spell for you I guess
because it's hard there is a link down
below we are the professional operation
around here anyway thanks for watching
guys we will do it again next week